Aaron Sampson here with a quick starter
guide for insurgency insurgency is an
easy game to get into its modes draw
influence for many of your favorite
titles and you'll find rush conquests
destroy the X objective and escort the
VIP all there if you want one life modes
insurgency has tactical operations if
you want respawns they're sustained
combat also included in insurgency is
co-op and we recommend you start there
to get your bearings the first thing
you'll need to do is pick one of several
fixed roles in your squad we enjoyed
starting as the engineer with a shotgun
because shotgun insurgency is one of the
few games that gets shotguns right if
you aim a shotgun at something it will
die
none of this if a guy's more than 15
feet away your shotgun fires tin foil
crap and co-op you'll find enemy AI to
be fairly aggressive and get a great
feel for how competitive matches will go
when you're done with that head over to
PvP modes
[Music]
[Music]
before any round starts an insurgency
you'll have a fixed number of points to
spend on your loadouts some of these
points have already been allocated for
you so you can say ditch the RPG and use
those points to add a suppressor to your
assault weapon we typically favored
weapon attachments and grenades - extra
ammo and armor I mean let's be honest
you're probably gonna die before you run
out of ammo and if you run out of ammo
you've probably already won
make sure to swap out that flashbang for
an actual grenade especially if you're
playing and destroy the whatever on an
objective mission you're gonna look real
dumb if you fight your way to an ammo
cache and all you can do is curse at it
when the round starts don't forget to
look at the players around you
unlike co-op you may either be America
or insurgents shoot the opposite
[Music]
nice shotgun there are small touches in
insurgencies combat to love such as the
extra time it takes to scope in on
magnified optics lack of a mini-map
aleni mechanic and teamwork being
heavily encouraged remember that this
game tilts towards the punishing side so
advanced slowly use cover slice your
pies and youth bounding tactics when
possible the support gunner in
particular can lay down suppressive fire
on request and should do so frequently
the overall feel of combat picks up
somewhere around where America's army
left off before that turned into the
more arcadey proving grounds so what do
you think about insurgency is a realism
a nice break from your battlefields and
call duties how do you feel about the
co-op of this game versus a war face do
you see the America's Army influence or
is this just all a half-life 2 mod let
us know in the comments below and thanks
for watching
you